beaucoup de monde des files d'attentes
et de la confusion
de cette gare routière des autocars
partent pour tous les coins de l'ukraine
et aussi pour la pologne et d'autres
pays de l'union européenne
j'ai peur ça panique je suis stressée je
suis inquiète je veux rentrer chez moi
on vient de l'ouest de l'ukraine nos
enfants sont là-bas sans leurs parents
qui travaillent ici à kiev
donc on rentre pour être avec nos
enfants de toute façon il n'y a plus de
boulot ici alors pourquoi rester mon
humeur et comme les temps aujourd'hui
douteuses pourtant ces jeunes ont changé
d'avis
regardez on ne peut pas partir d'ici on
est chez nous on n'a pas besoin d'aller
où que ce soit vous êtes d'où nous on
est de kiev on voulait partir mais
finalement non va rester
les places manquent les gens sont
nerveux la plupart des personnes à qui
j'ai parlé ici m'ont dit qu'il ne
s'attendait absolument pas à ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui